big news tonight Fox News Alert
Republicans on the House Intelligence
the committee has now ended this part of
the Russian probe and they conclude no
evidence of Trump Russia collusion
during the 2016 election we've been lied
to all this time earlier today prior to
that report I sat down with the vice
president Mike Pence for an exclusive
interview and I asked the vice president
about California refusing to enforce
federal immigration laws Joy Behar
attacking his faith and a lot more take
a look
you have sanctuary cities now you have a
sanctuary state of California the
president expected to go to California
tomorrow and then you have a defiant
Oakland mayor who is tipping off illegal
criminal illegal immigrants that ice and
border are coming their way what should
happen the Attorney General actually
went as far as to say that they'll use
every tool that they have against the
Oakland Mayor was that a crime in your
view is that obstruction of justice
we're a nation of laws Sean and all of
us who take the oath of office to serve
at every level take an oath to the
Constitution of the United States and
for state officials to the Constitution
of that state I mean to have an elected
mayor in Oakland California say that
they're not going to uphold the laws of
the United States of America worse
they're helping people that have broken
the law look it's it's the mayor's
actions are disgraceful on a couple
levels number one she's setting aside
her oath of office to uphold the laws of
the land and the rule of law but
secondly and I spoke to the Attorney
General about this the majority of
individuals were being targeted by
immigrations and Customs Enforcement had
a criminal record and so for the mayor
of Oakland to warn them in advance of
actions by ice personnel actually put
those law enforcement officers at risk
that's just utterly unacceptable I mean
look we we need to fix a broken
immigration system we need to fix this
system in a way that puts American
citizens and American workers first and
and we can do that but the answer is not
the kind of civil disobedience that we
see in municipal governments and in the
state of California that are sent
the saying we're going to set aside a
recognition of federal law simply
because we disagree with it that that's
it's not how the American system works
and we'll continue to call on on that
mayor and on leaders around the country
to respect the rule of law and put the
safety and security of our law
enforcement personnel first you recently
had an incident comments made by Joy
Behar of the view Bob Iger said that she
called you privately to apologize can
you bring us behind the scenes that tell
us what happened but she didn't say it
publicly although the original comments
that she made about Christianity were
made publicly well Sean my Christian
faith is the most important thing in my
life I mean my wife and I spend most
mornings a little bit of time in the
Bible a little bit of time in prayer and
we're very typical Americans I think the
tens of millions of Americans cherish
their faith and so when when I heard
that ABC had a program where my
Christian faith had been described as a
mental illness I thought it was
important for me to speak out not on my
own behalf you and I know that criticism
comes with public life but I felt it was
important that I defend the faith of
tens of millions of Americans against I
think against that kind of slander and
and I did so and you know I give joy
behar a lot of credit she picked up the
phone she called me she was very sincere
and she apologized him one of the things
my faith teaches me is Grace forgive as
you've been for so does mine but I'm not
as good as you look but but I said but I
said to joy of course I forgive you
that's it's part of part of my faith
experience but I did encourage her and
I'm still encouraging her to use the
form of that program or some other
public forum to apologize to tens of
millions of Americans who were who were
equally offended by what she it makes me
question the sincerity of because you're
right it wasn't just a shot against you
was against and I'm a Christian anybody
of faith well but but for me
it was never about me I mean understood
you know my son you don't take it
personally no I didn't take it
personally but but in in I just thought
it was important in in this moment that
I speak out on behalf of the faith of
tens of millions of Americans and my
hope is that the joy and and and others
on the airwaves will come to appreciate
the the the meaning and and and if I can
say the joy that kind of youth and
respect that last question 20:18 we
expected the Democrats expected the big
blue wave in Texas that never happened
tomorrow there's an important race going
on in the Pennsylvania 18th
congressional district a lot at stake
for you for the President of the country
if God forbid Nancy Pelosi became the
speaker again well it's it's the only
thing at stake is everything I mean if
you like a growing economy if you like
three million new jobs if you like a
president rebuilding our military having
America standing tall in the world again
fighting for free fair and reciprocal
trade appointing conservatives to the
courts and in cutting taxes then what
will happen in Pennsylvania 18 tomorrow
is about a whole lot more than the two
candidates that are on the ballot and
the fall election is just the same look
the president I have both campaigned for
Rick's account he would be a fantastic
member of Congress wore the uniform of
the United States for nearly two decades
and has an extraordinary credentials he
was just in endorsed by the Pittsburgh
post-gazette on on Sunday morning but
that election to me and this fall's
elections are really more about the
direction of the country and the people
of Pennsylvania have a great opportunity
to send a message that they support the
direction the president said also about
those crumbs that Nancy Pelosi talks
about yeah it really is I mean let's
let's make no mistake about if the
Democrats took over the Congress in this
fall's elections Nancy Pelosi would be
Speaker of the House again and we don't
have to wonder what that would be like I
was in the Congress though
time it happened Shawn and it's all
about raising taxes and more regulations
and the dodd-frank bill that's killed
community banking and lending to small
business owners and and that of course
they forced Obamacare on the country is
that disaster that that was I mean we
know that they would want to turn back
all the progress the president has made
and so that's why the president was in
Pennsylvania Saturday night that's why
he and I are going to be campaigning all
over the country because making sure
that we reelect strong conservative
majorities on Capitol Hill to continue
to partner with this president it's
exactly how we're going to keep making
America great again
mr. vice president good to see you
always great to have you thank you so
much for your time we appreciate it
great to see you Sean